okay today I'm going to talk to you
about genetic diagrams we're showing it
to do a Punnett square I'm gonna show
you how to do a monohybrid cross and
we're going to see how sex is determined
by using a punnett square
okay so let's imagine first of all we
have two people that are going to have a
baby here we have dad and he has that
genotype of two little bees and we have
month and she has this genotype of one
big bee and one little bee month so just
to remind about what this means the big
be the capital B is the gene for brown
eyes and it is dominant you can tell
that it's dominant because it's a
capital letter and there's the little B
which it stands for blue eyes remember
if it's recessive we need two of those
particular alleles in order to have that
characteristic okay so what upon it
squared the whole point of a Punnett
Square is to determine what the
percentage chances of the baby either
having blue eyes or brown eyes now when
when the dad he produces sperm cells
there's a 50% chance that that allele
will be in sperm so and there's a 50%
chance that that one will be so there's
a 50% chance you'll produce that and a
50% chance he'll produce that now
because mum is heterozygous she has one
of each type of allele there's a 50%
chance that her egg cells will contain
that B if the dominant allele and a 50%
chance that it will still contain that
allele that recessive allele so all we
need to do now to complete the punnett
square is we see the combinations of
these different gametes so if this sperm
cell joins with that egg cell we're
going to have Big B little B if this one
joins with that one we're gonna have
little B little B if this one joins of
that one we're gonna have Big B little B
and if that one joins with that one
we're gonna have a little B little B so
which ones are brown eyes so this child
here because they have that dominant
allele
they'd have brown eyes this two child
would have brown eyes this one a blue
eyes this one with her blue eyes so
what's the percentage chance that they
have blue eyes it's a 50% chance of blue
eyes please notice guys you always use
the same letter even if let's say this
was
if these didn't start with the same
letter these always do so it's always
the capital of one letter and the
lowercase of the same letter now a
monohybrid cross that shows exactly the
same thing so let's imagine we're
dealing with this time someone with
cystic fibrosis so cystic fibrosis is a
recessive disorder if someone has that
genotype it means that they are a
carrier of cystic fibrosis meaning they
don't have it themselves but they can
pass it on if they have two recessive
alleles they have cystic fibrosis so
let's imagine let's imagine we have two
parents dad and mum now these two
genotypes let's say dad and mum are both
carriers so neither of them have cystic
fibrosis but both of them have that
recessive allele that carried from
cystic fibrosis that could be passed on
to the next generation so let's just
have a quick thing the first thing that
you need to do is you need to show the
different gametes that would be produced
so 50% of dads gametes are going to have
that C the capital one and 50% are going
to have that recessive allele the
lowercase one please notice if you're
using the same letter make it really
clear which one's capital which one's
lowercase I mean not the same letter but
if they look the same so the capital C
in the lowercase e we need to really
make sure they're different sizes okay
same with mum so her two different
gametes would be this and this so what
we now need to do is show the different
combinations of fertilization so first
of all if that sperm joins with that egg
there so if that sperm joined with that
egg there we'd have this zygote being
formed
this however this sperm could also form
go with that egg so the next thing the
combination would be that with that
which would form big seat little C so
this person would be a carrier that's
looked at both permutations or both kind
of combinations with dads with that
particular sperm what about if they're
produced that sperm so instead we'd see
that sperm mixing with that egg there
for fertilizing that egg there
so we'd have Big C little C and finally
you can have this one joining with this
one to make a little C little C so let's
just quickly think about the offspring
here
so this first person doesn't have cystic
fibrosis at all these two here are
carriers which mean they don't have it
but they could pass it on and finally
person on the end has cystic fibrosis
okay so I'm going to show you one more
thing which is just how sex can be
determine by using the punnett square as
well so men all men have the chromosomes
X X so they have two X chromosomes on
the 23rd chromosome
they're both X's whereas women women's
chromosomes they have an X and a Y
chromosome now Y chromosome is dominant
which means we only need one Y
chromosome in order for this person for
in order for the offspring to be a baby
to be baby to be a woman be female so
let's quickly have a look at the punnett
square so again let's think about this
right now so when the man is producing
sex cells there's a 50% chance you'll
have that X chromosome in and a 50%
chance he'll have that X chromosome in
when a woman is producing X cells
there's a 50% chance we'll have that X
in and there's a fifth-century I'll have
that Y in there wait a minute sorry I
just do that in that color
makes it a bit easier okay so when we
look at the punnett square this X with
this X that would be male this X with
this X that would be male this X with
this why that would be female and this X
with this why that would be female so
this is why there's always a 50% chance
it's a 50% chance of being male and 50%
chance of being female because always
reproducing is between a man and a woman
so we'll always have this punnett square
happening so that's why there's always a
50% chance of the baby being a boy 50%
chance of the baby being a girl thank
you